find log of 34 using a calculator round
your answer to the nearest hundredth so
someone just asks you the log of 34 if
you see this like this you might what's
the base if they just if they don't
include a base year they use the word
log the implicit base is base 10 so this
is the same thing as log base 10 of 34
which is essentially saying the power
that I have to raise 10 to to get to 34
and if I take 10 to the first power i
get 10 in 10 to the second power is
going to be 134 is between 10 and 100 so
it's going to be someplace in between 1
and 2 the power that have to raise 10 to
to get to 34 but we are allowed to use a
calculator so let's use a calculator
then we're going to round to the nearest
hundredth so let me get my ti-85 out
it's going to be a little different
depending on the calculator use but on
most of the TI graphing calculators you
see this log button right over here and
so that is base 10 you don't see that
little 10 subscript right over here but
when you just see log that assumes base
10 so if I write log of 34 this is the
power I need to raise 10 to to get to 34
and that gets us to one point we wrapped
around to the hundredths 1.53 the
thousands place is a 1 so we do round
down so 1.53 so this is equal to or i
should say maybe say approximately equal
to 1.5 3 and we're done